well the united states capitol was on
quote high alert
yesterday the national guard was ready
fencing all in place security perimeters
fortified
the house of representative
representatives canceled its sessions
for the day
this was all done because as the media
constantly reminded us
in the days leading up to yesterday
march 4th there was supposed to be
a threat of right-wing terrorist
violence
the right-wing maga domestic terrorists
had threatened to try to overtake the
capitol building on march 4th we were
told
and this was all part of again this is
what we're told all part of some plot
that as i understand it
involved the belief that march 4th was
the true inauguration day and on that
day donald trump would rise
from the ashes to his rightful throne
and call on his followers to uh
also rise up in vengeance and destroy
his adversaries
now the strange thing is that i never
heard about this conspiracy theory
and this plot from any actual right
wingers i never heard any right winger
talk about this i never saw any right
winger post about this
i don't know of any right wingers who
know of any right wingers who talked
about that or posted about that
this was a far-reaching widely believed
conspiracy theory on the right
that nobody on the right seemed to be
aware of very strange
yet it justified the further military
occupation of dc
and the drama and theatrics of the house
of representatives shutting down in a
panic
and then on march 4th came then march
4th came yesterday and it went
and nothing happened there was you may
have noticed no attack
no insurrection nothing now this
could be because the right-wing
insurrectionists have
invisibility cloaks and actually did
invade the capital but nobody saw them
and if the terrorists have that kind of
technology then we're definitely in
trouble
i mean we have to admit right but the
other possibility something we should at
least consider is that there was never
any plot at all
that this was all an invention something
that existed only in the fevered
imagination of the left and the media
i mean we certainly can't rule out
either possibly the invisibility cloak
thing is
technically possible but but i tend to
think that the latter
is probably the case there was never any
plot
if there were any q anon people who
believe that march 4th was the real
inauguration day or whatever
it was a small smattering of them and
not nearly enough to justify
the continued military occupation of our
nation's capital
so where do we go from here there was
supposed to be right-wing violence on
inauguration day
there was no violence then they said
that there would be the violence on
march 4th and that didn't happen either
the military occupation of dc is
starting to remind me of the 15 days to
slow the spread
thing something with a definitive end
end date originally
but then suddenly becomes ambiguous and
endless
they put a certain measure in place for
a particular reason
then when that reason no longer applies
they find another one
and that's why we can't expect the
military to go home and the fencing to
come down
now that now that another predicted
right-wing insurrection turned out to be
a dud
there are reports today that the united
states capitol police department has
requested an extension
of the national guard presence in the
capitol for another 30 days
or rather 60 days sorry another two
months another two months of the us
capital under military occupation why
for what reason more threats of course
but what threats well you heard about
the threats on inauguration day that
didn't amount to anything
and you heard about the threats on a
march 4th that didn't amount to anything
now get ready for the next big thing the
next big hype
march 20th you're probably going to be
hearing a lot about march 20th
in the coming days not not from
right-wing insurrectionists
or q anon conspiracy theorists but from
the media allegedly reporting what those
other groups are allegedly saying
so here's the um here's the newsweek
headline
it says q anon theorists switch date to
march
20th after no after no trump
inauguration
um after no trump inauguration call the
fourth false flag
then the article goes on to talk about
how q anon people branded
march 4th a false flag and never plan to
do anything on that day which again
raises the question as to why
you know why they canceled the house
session and they stood on high alert
if now the media is telling us that oh
yeah well the me the q anon people said
that
march 4th was never a thing but where
does this march
20th date come from well in the newsweek
article you have to go
all the way to the end of that article
and then you find this here's what it
says some q anon supporters
seem to rebrand the march 4th conspiracy
in the wake of
of community suspicion while two
individuals affiliated with the false
theories simply suggested that trump's
inauguration
would take place sometime in the spring
one man identified
as ken told washington post reporter
dave weigel that the former president
will be inaugurated again on march 20th
in comments over the weekend
ken also believes that trump is still in
full command of the military
and biden is acting as president as a
ruse while the pope and others are
rounded up
according to weigel the upcoming date
will mark the 167th anniversary of the
republican party's founding
former members of the whig party are
said to have technically established
the gop during a meeting in ripon
wisconsin
on march 20th 1854.
oh yes march 20th 1854 the
technical founding of the republican
party isn't that a date that all of us
right-wingers know
so well and care so much about
i talk to conservatives all the time i
said what are you doing for march 20th
big day it's when the whig party
technically formed a republican party
big stuff so that's it um
a guy named ken newsweek is pushing
in its headline a new date for an
insurrection based on something that a
guy named
ken told another guy
that's really it i i'm not
cherry-picking and pulling no that
that's it in the newsweek article that's
all they got they got a guy named ken
they don't even explain anything about
ken who is ken
is he from a a forum is he from reddit
is he just like did this washington post
reporter stumble across this guy on a
park bench somewhere
is it his neighbor his uncle his cousin
ah just this is what ken says
this is how journalism works in the
modern age it works namely by
trying to conjure things into reality by
reporting them
as a reality before they are a reality
reality
the game here is completely transparent
the media wants
some kind of violent right-wing
demonstration
and so it is itself inventing conspiracy
theories that it hopes the right will
adopt
and even if the media is ultimately
disappointed and the violence never
materializes
still the threat the entirely invented
threat
is useful enough on its own useful to
guys like congressman jamal bowman
who was on msnbc recently explaining why
the city has to remain fortified even
after all this here's what he says
what do you feel or how do you feel
about the decision to extend the
security perimeter
and the presence of the national guard
at the capitol
it's something we have to do
unfortunately because the
threat of white nationalists and and and
white supremacists
is real you know they are continuing to
organize and galvanize
across this country uh there are many
examples of them
infiltrating uh law enforcement across
this country so we have to make sure the
capital is protected and our
elected officials are protected but we
also have to be proactive
you know we cannot take the threat of
white nationalism
lightly you know over the last several
years uh they've made their presence
uh felt whether it's the um uh the tree
of life synagogue
uh shooting the christ church uh
shooting which happened
overseas as well as the ame church
shooting
and then obviously the january 6
insurrection we have to do everything we
can to protect ourselves and protect the
capital
but we also have to be proactive in
dealing with the issue of white
nationalism
in a very serious way did you catch that
we have to do everything we can to
protect ourselves
a politician saying that the government
has to do everything it can to protect
him sure i mean he's asking to be
protected from a
non-existent threat even so talk about
saying the quiet part out loud
do everything you can to protect me
no in fact jamal the government
should not do everything it can to
protect you
not at all there's a whole lot it can do
that it shouldn't do it's doing some of
those things right now yes
the government can fortify the nation's
capital and permanently militarize it
to protect politicians to protect itself
but it shouldn't
but this is how bowman and his democrat
cohorts see it
do everything to protect him and almost
nothing to protect regular american
citizens his constituents
from violent blm riding in our cities or
from the ordinary everyday violence and
bloodshed that wreaks havoc
in those same cities but look
none of this means that uh our elected
representatives lack courage i don't
want you to think that it would be
unfair of me not to make
note of democratic representative al
green
who did demonstrate unparalleled courage
and heroism yesterday in the midst of
the attack by invisible or possibly
non-existent insurrectionist
here's the hill with that report
representative al green is sending a
message to q anon and right-wing
extremist threats by sitting on the
capitol steps on thursday
the day authorities warned militia
groups were potentially planning another
breach of the building
he told the hill quote i want to make a
statement to let people know
those who would threaten those of us who
cherish this freedom that we have here
that we refuse to allow those threats to
negate our freedom
capitol police and the fbi have
cautioned that militia groups that took
part in the deadly insurrection at the
capitol on january
6 when a group of trump supporters
attempted to disrupt the certification
of the electoral college votes had
drafted plans for a second attack on
march 4th
wow wow the bravery
he is sitting on the steps behind a
barbed wire fence
patrolled by armed national guardsmen
and staring down a crowd that consists
of media members and a handful of
pedestrians who happen to
be walking by truly the world has never
seen courage
such as this for this man to sit in what
is right now the safest place on earth
in spite of the alleged threats of a
handful of nutty troll accounts on the
internet
well i for one am stunned
stunned sure it takes more courage to
simply
walk down the street in chicago a lot
more actually than to do what he did
but still let's not focus on any of that
let's focus on him
which is what he wants us to do very
inspiring very courageous
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated